corruption alert cronyism alert Dow
Chemical makes a lot of money from
chloro p4p rofo s-- diazinon and Malay
Theon okay
there are a couple of problems for Dow
Chemical though Corp IRA folks do you
have any idea how to say that oh geez
chlorpyrifos is tough chlorpyrifos
I don't know chloro Pyrrha folks a
little tired I think you're putting an
extra o in there based on mining of it
but why not at this point just throwing
whatever vowels you want chlorpyrifos
was originally derived from a nerve gas
developed by Nazi Germany that sounds
bad
that's not actually the biggest problem
for Dow Chemical which says a lot
studies by federal scientists have found
that chlorpyrifos diazinon and malathion
are harmful to almost 1,800 critically
threatened or endangered species that's
bad news however there's some good news
on the horizon for Dow Chemical first of
all the EPA which would normally be
charged with or tasked with dealing with
this is now run by a climate change
skeptic very friendly to companies like
Dow Chemical his name is Scott Pruett
last month he said he was going to
reverse an Obama era effort to bar the
use of dows chlorpyrifos pesticide on
food after peer-reviewed studies found
that even small levels of exposure can
hinder child brain development which is
a pretty serious thing but it gets even
better for Dow Chemical than just having
Scott Pruett in the EPA their CEO Andrew
Liveris
is good buddies with our president
Donald Trump Dow Chemical spent 13
million dollars on lobbying last year
and they also made the very nice
generous beautiful donation of a million
dollars to pay for Donald Trump's
inauguration and now lawyers
representing Dow Chemical and two other
companies that manufacture some of the
other pesticides in question have sent
letters to the head of the EPA as well
as the head of the Department of
Commerce and the head of the Fish and
Wildlife Service saying listen why don't
you set aside the results of these
studies saying that the studies are
funded
mentally flawed drawer set them aside
nothing to see here right I'd love to
see their critiques as to why these
studies are flawed if they're going
after the methodology or if they want to
propose one of their own studies because
just to ask them to put it aside makes
it seem as though yeah that's actually
true what they have to say but we don't
want the public to hear about it they do
have some studies they funded which very
surprising I know show that these
chemicals are far less damaging then the
nonpartisan studies show it showed them
to be what's the solution to this so I
mean it there's no simple or narrow
solution we obviously need total
campaign finance reform but that alone
isn't going to fix the broader issue we
need stricter ethics rules we need
stricter conflicts of interest conflict
of interest rules but that's not going
to be enough do we need as we spoke
about earlier some more specific
qualifications to be President more than
just being old enough and being a
natural-born citizen I just don't know
what they would be in order to prevent
this type of garbage from going on do we
go to the popular vote and and fix
gerrymandering once and for all none of
these ideas that I'm presenting
individually would solve the rampant
crony corruption that we have but maybe
altogether they would all those things
sound nice but it would also just be
great to have an environmental
protection agency that protects the
environment it looks out for the public
and for wildlife and actually tries to
restrict corporations from doing
whatever they want it's such a
problematic and huge issue that it's
difficult to even get my mind around how
much would need to change to fix the
corruption that is just inherent in our
system and on our reddit discussion
forum on our Facebook page people talk
about issues of corruption a lot and
it's it's just such a monster and at the
bottom of it Pat why would the people
who use the current system to get into
power fundamentally change it that seems
like they're acting against their own
best interests which our elected
officials rarely do right it's one of
those things that you'll never be able
to solve completely but that doesn't
mean that you can't take active measures
to curve it right yeah I guess although
we don't see much of an impetus for
anybody doing that as well
sad low-energy and sad I would say
patreon.com slash david pakman show
David
Hockman dot-com slash membership check
out either or both support the program
this is independent alternative media
today's program is made possible in part
by texture at a time when it feels like
it's never been harder to find the truth
supporting Free Press is really really
important and from its inception texture
has supported journalism not just by
offering access to great magazines but
also financially because a portion of
every subscribers fee goes directly to
the publishers the texture app has gone
beyond just giving you the magazine
itself it actually makes it easy for you
to find and enjoy the articles that you
actually want to read with daily
recommendations exclusive interactive
features videos and more texture makes
magazines easy and there are so many
great magazines out there like Vanity
Fair Rolling Stone Popular Mechanics New
York Magazine even the vegetarian times
for producer Pat texture is searchable
you can mark what you like check out
back issues view bonus video content
they even curate articles and magazines
just for you texture is normally $9.99 a
month and you get over 200 magazines but
if you sign up right now at texture comm
slash Pakman you'll get a 14-day free
trial
why subscribe to just a couple of
magazines when you can have all of your
favorites on your smartphone or tablet
all the time for way less texture was
also selected as one of Apple's top 2016
iPad apps so start your free trial now
and download the texture app at texture
calm /pa que ma n